lakovic 19 été fatale pour la librairie
olivieri qui depuis 35 ans faisait la
promotion et la diffusion de la
littérature québécoise pour moi vraiment
je suis triste aujourd'hui quand j'ai vu
ça j'ai vu spécialement pour voir
c'était vraiment sympathique aussi d'une
grande tristesse
jetez un oeil parmi un paquet d'autres
deuil à faire encore trop attristé par
la nouvelle ses fondateurs n'ont pas
voulu accorder d'entrevue
mais se sont exprimés dans un message
sur facebook qui a recueilli de
nombreuses réactions des gens 2016
la librairie avait frôlé la fermeture en
raison de dettes de près d'un million de
dollars le rachat par renaud bray lui
avait permis de continuer ses opérations
mais la crise des dernières semaines
aura été le coup de grâce
la librairie était fermé depuis le 20
mars sur mesure liée à la pandémie de la
corvette 19
il ya aussi des travaux et qui se font
juste à côté la librairie qui vient un
peu limité l'accès à la librairie la
pandémie arrive survient nous prend par
surprise personne le vit venir
puis c'est venu un peu au bout de nos
efforts malgré les mesures des deux mis
en place par le gouvernement et la
réouverture prochaine du commerce au
détail la situation demeure difficile
pour certaines librairies
un libraire fait une marge bénéficiaire
d'environ 2,1 points 5 % sur la
librairie donc des presses
malheureusement c'est pas une solution
mais sans aide gouvernementale
on a une crème qu'on ne soit pas la
seule librairie qui a fermé les ventes
ont baissé de 70% dans les librairies
indépendantes depuis le début de la
pandémie
mais pour garder la tête hors de l'eau
si libraire mise sur les ventes en ligne
qui ont explosé
il s est libre à point c'est à qui
réunit plus d'une centaines de
librairies indépendantes au québec qui
partagent leurs inventaires ensemble
c'est un secret bien gardé
depuis la crise et 1500 % d'augmentation
la réouverture prochaine des commerces
au détail est une bonne nouvelle pour le
secteur et cette libraire est impatient
de retrouver ses clients on a hâte de
revoir donc les liens ne pouvoir les
élever mon livre on les croise mais de
pouvoir
vous les accueillir dans la librairie
qui peut ce but qui nous ici nabi
alexandre charting radio canada montréal